[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance lost in the cacophony of
launched missiles in Syria and dropped
bombs in Afghanistan and rattled sabers
in Korea drowned out by the clamoring
dissidents of conflicting policies about
China at Assad and NATO shouted over by
the crises of Sean Spicer and Paul
Manafort and Eric Trump and always
forever distracted from by the little
were and clicking sounds of a recorder
being switched on and off supported by
the remorseless background drumbeat of
the Russian election scandal there is a
terrifying new fact the president is
getting crazy
this statement is somewhat akin to
rhetorically asking if today here in
hell it is hotter than it was yesterday
but in the last week just in the last
week the feather-light grip on reality
of trump's tiny hands has seemingly
gotten much looser and much looser much
faster the most obvious though hardly
the most disturbing evidence of some
kind of deepening illness or damage or
madness or what does the cause matter
any longer was the latest barrage of
tweets like the fake media parentheses
not real media and parentheses tweet
Monday morning but especially the string
of tweets on Easter in 83 short minutes
Trump moved from a simpletons
rationalization of his complete 180 on
Chinese currency manipulation to the
implication that he had forgotten it was
a holiday and he needed to say Happy
Easter
- boasting about his election as if it
were the answer to everything - using
that election as an excuse for reneging
on one of his campaign promises -
paranoid fantasies about paid protesters
- then insisting his election should not
be the answer to everything - a random
boast about American military strength
which if it were connected to the
previous tweet could easily and
terrifyingly be read as a tacit threat
to suppress American protesters with
American military force the president is
getting crazy
a it is possible that this string of
five-word explosions could be only that
merely a sign of a lazy damaged
unfocused mind wandering off on its own
again
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder
or adult attention disorder or not
really an adult sanity disorder just
taking a stroll on a lazy holiday
weekend but this wasn't a lazy holiday
weekend literally 24 hours before those
tweets there was urgent reason to think
we might be bombing North Korea
there had been no accord there had been
no stand down and had there been no
Korean missiles self-destructing and
dropping infinitely from the sky there
would have been no relief from the
crisis and Sunday morning the quote
president unquote was obsessed with how
many votes he got in the electoral
college five months ago as if anyone
anywhere at any time besides him thinks
that this week victory there is by
itself an explanation and a
justification for his broken promises
about releasing his taxes and North
Korea North Korea went from inspiring a
joke on Saturday Night Live with Melissa
McCarthy as Sean Spicer suggesting we
should eat all the chocolate eggs we
want because it was going to be our last
Easter on earth to being relegated to
almost an actor thought to the real
Trump's rationalizations about his other
broken promises about designating China
as a currency manipulator in the
disordered mind of the commander in
chief North Korea had been figuratively
if not literally the end of the world
but overnight was reduced to being not
nearly as much of a threat as the Trump
tax return protesters the president is
getting crazy her and it's not as if he
had spent the preceding week or even the
preceding 72 hours focused just on North
Korea in our collective national trip
inside the kaleidoscopic roller coaster
mind of this unstable man does anybody
even remember the moab the 22,000 pound
bomb dropped in Afghanistan or the stunt
attack on the Syrian Air Base that
didn't even have the ability to disable
the Syrian air base the Moab was
Thursday 7 days after Syrian Thursday's
Thursday's have apparently become blow
stuff up days and of course Trump had
already forgotten into which country he
had those missiles fired so what happens
is I said we've just launched 59
heading to Iraq and I want you to know
that and he was eating his cake and he
was silent and Maria Bartiromo who used
to be a journalist interrupts him and
says to Syria yes
heading towards Syria in other words
we've just launched 59 missiles heading
towards Syria no those aren't other
words those things quote we've just
launched 59 missiles heading to Iraq and
quote we've just launched 59 missiles
heading towards Syria these are not two
different descriptions of the same thing
they are two different things with two
utterly different world-changing sets of
consequences and there are two things
that a president says in an interview in
which he also expresses his amazement
about the unmanned missiles as if there
were manned missiles and the only thing
he says with clear conviction or unmod
memory is quote we had the most
beautiful piece of chocolate cake that
you've ever seen they are two things a
president says when he is getting crazy
only a president who is getting crazier
would admit going into a meeting with
the president of China with a
long-standing assumption that the
Chinese could just wave a magic wand and
stop North Korea but figuring out this
was not true after only ten minutes of
conversation while not realizing that
there are nine year-old children in this
country with a better grasp on North
Korea than he has only a president who
is getting crazy
I would flip-flop on the import-export
Bank and flip-flop on NATO and flip-flop
on his own promise on Chinese currency
manipulation and flip-flop on his own
promise on his tax returns and flip-flop
on his Syria policy and flip-flop on his
top advisor and all of that and just
barely over a week while bombing two
countries and threatening a third and
only correctly remembering two of their
three names we don't like to admit this
here but it has often served our
American purposes just as certainly as
it has served Kim Jong Un's purposes to
have leaders or indeed even commanders
in chief who verged on seeming madness
Kissinger used to tell the Russians that
Richard Nixon was a madman Ronald Reagan
let the same country believe he actually
viewed them as the evil empire from Star
Wars Barry Goldwater wanted to nuke
North
nom and George Wallace's
vice-presidential candidate was an ex
general who wanted to nuke Vietnam
Russia and maybe China and the Russian
records from the Cuban Missile Crisis
suggest Khrushchev thought John F
Kennedy might have been literally insane
it can be a tactic but it can only work
as a tactic if there remains the
likelihood that the president really is
not crazy and with every passing week
and every passing day and every passing
hour there is less and less evidence
that this president really is not crazy
what is rapidly becoming the Paramount
fact of the 21st century the event
overshadowing everything else from 9/11
to climate change continues to be
largely ignored ignored even though it
is an existential threat to the future
of mankind there are millions of
Americans millions of others around the
world even millions who despise these
policies and hate this man who are
standing so close to the BARC
that they can't see the trees let alone
the forest president let me eat cake
over here is crazy getting crazier and
he will descend quickly into full-on
hallucinatory meet my invisible friend
why do we have nukes if we don't use
nukes crazy while our only hope to
remove him our political system
destroyed by 25 years of utter
partisanship and complete denial and the
placement of a price tag on virtually
everything and everybody in our country
is no longer capable of even pulling off
a successful White House Easter egg hunt
he is getting crazy a resist piece by
the way if you enjoy these I am proud to
announce that coming in October my book
of these commentaries called Trump is
effing crazy it'll be available wherever
books are available